all right we're gonna tell you
everything that you need to know about
the Las Vegas massacre that occurred
late last night we're gonna give you all
the information on background all the
political hot takes and why we should
wait for all the information to come out
plus we'll talk about Puerto Rico and
the fallout therefrom I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show horrifying
act of evil last night about 10:00 p.m.
in Las Vegas a shooter opens fire from
the 32nd floor of the Mandalay Bay Hotel
overlooking a giant 22 thousand person
country music concert that was happening
the shooter ends up murdering almost 60
people the number continues to rise and
has injured well over 500 people so it's
the worst massacre the worst mass
shooting in American history of course
this is leading to all sorts of
political hot takes without any
information I want to discuss a bunch of
things bunch of angles on this
particular incident I'm gonna give you
all the information I'm going to explain
the the hot takes that are being
presented and I also want to talk about
the problem of evil and what exactly how
we break down evil how do we fight evil
how is it possible to stop situations
like this or can situations like this
attacks on soft targets by people who
heretofore had had really no criminal
background how okay can we stop those
things it possible to stop those things
we're going to talk about all of this
but first I just want to say thank you
to our sponsors quickly over at zip
recruiters so right now you're looking
to hire up you're looking to staff up
the economy's doing well but you don't
know where to get the best employees
well that's why you need a zip recruiter
with zip recruiter you can post your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards with just one clip then zip
recruiter puts its smart matching
technology to work actively notifying
qualified candidates about your job
within minutes of posting so you receive
the best possible matches we use it over
here at the Daily wire that's why zip
recruiter is different unlike other
hiring sites it doesn't depend on the
right candidates finding you it finds
them for you you post the job and they
already have all the resumes and it just
hooks you right up no wonder 80 percents
of employers who post on zip recruiter
must they do get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire
and right now you can post jobs on zip
recruiter for free again that's for free
@ 0q dot-com slash daily wire that zip
recruiter
komm slash daily wire you're gonna get
the best employees if you use zip
recruiter Bar None zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire that allows you to post
your jobs for free go check it out and
make your company better today with zip
recruiter okay so here is the quick
backgrounds on what exactly happened
last night first I can show you this
video there's a lot of video that has
been emerging from the incident because
obviously in a crowd of 22,000 people at
a concert there are a lot of folks who
are filming the concert and then shots
ring out and it sounds like an automatic
weapon it sounds like someone is firing
a machine gun from about 300 yards about
three football fields away from the
Mandalay Bay and you can see it looming
up there in the skyline and people just
being mowed down and in this concert
[Music]
[Applause]
ingest unbelievably horrifying
[Music]
so war zone right in the middle of one
of America's largest and most prosperous
cities and I mean just overwhelming the
the hospitals right now if you can you
should go out and you should give blood
we have a list over at Ely we're kind of
ways that you can help with with this
situation so you don't feel helpless
obviously pray for the world pray for
the country and pray for the victims
just horrifying all the way around here
was president from press conference this
morning at which he spoke about what had
just happened my fellow Americans we are
joined together today in sadness shock
and grief last night a gunman opened
fire on a large crowd at a country music
concert in Las Vegas Nevada he brutally
murdered more than 50 people and wounded
hundreds more I want to thank the Las
Vegas metropolitan Police Department and
all of the first responders for their
courageous efforts and for helping to
save the lives of so many the speed with
which they acted is miraculous and
prevented further loss of life to have
found the shooter so quickly after the
first shots were fired is something for
which we will always be thankful and
grateful
it shows what true professionalism is
all about so president Trump ordered the
flags around the United States be flown
at half-staff in honor of the victims it
is the worst massacre the worst mass
shooting in American history here's what
we know about the shooter his 64 years
olds name is Steven paddock from
Mesquite Nevada there's no motive as of
yet people you know whenever these sorts
of things happen everybody in the news
industry immediately goes to social
media and begins trying to uncover all
of the facts about the guy none of that
has come out so far apparently according
Cory Rose over at the local news he was
known to local police but they don't
really have a criminal history they've
been reports that he lived in a
retirement home but this remain under
this remains unconfirmed
at this time the police have checked out
his girlfriend woman in Marylou danly
they've said that she had nothing to do
with it at this point they're now saying
that he's a fully automatic weapon and
upon searching the suspects home
officers found several weapons so I'll
explain to you what the law is regarding
fully automatic weapons in the United
States suffice it to say federal law has
forbid the sale of fully automatic
rifles in the United States since 1986
so the idea that this was you know some
guy just went down to the local gun shop
and bought a gun if this was indeed a
fully automatic weapon that is that is
not correct and you can hear on that
tape it sounds like a fully automatic
weapon right the difference between a
fully auto and a semi-auto for people
who are not familiar with guns is that a
semi-auto you would here burst fire and
usually those bursts are three bullets
so in that case you hear a continuous
rat rabbit adding of a machine gun like
you wouldn't war movie that's what a
fully automatic weapon sounds like there
is a modification that you can make to
to some semi-automatic weapons they can
ruin the gun it can also if you if you
do it right then it can apparently make
it fully automatic or there's also a
modification that you can make that
allows you to fire using the recoil from
the fully on from the semi-automatic
rifle basically you hold your finger in
one place and then there's a stock that
you a gun stock that you put on the gun
that bounces back and so they sort of
rattles against your shoulder and that
allows it to sort of act like a fully
automatic weapon but we don't have
evidence that that's what was happening
as of yet according to Las Vegas Sheriff
Joe Lombardo the motive remains unclear
but it's not suspected to be terrorism
this all according to Amanda Presta
Jacomo over at Daily wire says he said
at this point we believe it was a local
individual he resides here locally I'm
not at liberty to give you his place of
residence yet because it's an ongoing
investigation we don't know what his
belief system was at the time right now
we believe he's the sole aggressor at
this point the scene is static do not
believe rumors that Isis is putting out
claiming credit for this Isis does this
sometimes Isis has claimed credit for
crimes it did not commit because it
wants to make it appear as listen to act
of terrorism now it may come out later
that it was an act of radical Islamic
terror but we have no evidence of that
so far so please do not spread rumors of
that if you're gonna talk about it say
there's no evidence so far because there
is no evidence of it so far so again the
girlfriend was a poor was reportedly
traveling with him but they are
suggesting that that she has nothing to
do with it at the
point she was apparently found outside
the country and paddock reportedly used
her ID to get into the hotel he was
found dead by officers in a hotel room
on the 32nd floor
apparently when it blew open the door he
killed himself the suspects brother to
give a TV interview in which he said
that there were no warning signs and
said that he just snapped now we're
gonna continue updating and providing of
that information as the show goes on
live also go over to daily wire for
real-time updates so those are all the
facts that's what we know okay those are
all the things that we know that's
pretty much it I mean like I'm not aware
of anything else that we know based on
that slim coterie of fact people are
immediately drawing the conclusions they
want to draw and this is one of the big
problems in modern politics is that
people are immediately they have preset
conclusions that they want to get to
such as gun control good gun control
useful and they immediately take this
and they just shove the square peg into
the round hole of gun control even if
there's no real evidence at this point
that gun control would have made this
any better so Stephen Gostkowski over at
the Washington free beacon he has a very
good run down over at Washington free
beacon talking about exactly what what
exactly
the gun laws are that are on the books
at this point and as he says the gun
laws with regard to machine guns are and
have been quite strict for a long time
so since 1986 that is the case since
1986 it has been illegal in the United
States to buy a fully automatic long gun
fully automatic firearms this is
Gutowski talking is fully automatic
firearms that were registered under the
National Firearms Act before 1986 were
grandfathered in and are still illegal
however in order to obtain a legal fully
automatic firearm you must apply to the
ATF pay a $200 tax and register with the
ATF the ATF has a registry of every
legally owned fully automatic firearm
and informs local law enforcement of all
who owned them in their jurisdiction
fingerprints and photographs are
required to be submitted along with the
registration application in practice
there are several hundred thousand
legally registered fully automatic
firearms in the United States but they
are very hard to obtain and beyond the
registration process what can't a which
can take up to nine months to complete
the price of fully automatic firearms is
extremely high the low end of fully
automatic firearms is around five
figures per gun he says he's seen fully
automatic firearms in the $300,000 range
the reason this is relevant is because
what you'll hear is that they're
unregulated this is untrue
that is a gun myth now they're a bunch
of people who are putting a sigh or
putting aside any semblance of reality
in fact in order to promulgate this
political agenda Hillary Clinton is one
of those so Barack Obama does the right
thing he tweets out basically that this
is just horrifying Hillary Clinton
however can't stop herself so she tweets
out she starts in this way Las Vegas we
are grieving with you the victims those
who lost loved ones the responders and
all affected by this cold-blooded
massacre and then she continues along
these lines she says the crowd fled at
the son of gunshots it took her
legitimately five minutes to go
political with this she says the crowd
fled at the sound of gunshots imagine
the deaths if the shooter had a silencer
which the NRA wants to make easier to
get so within minutes
she's already politicizing this and
blaming the NRA without any evidence the
NRA had anything to do with this there
was no silencer on the gun obviously and
apparently she continued along these
lines as well but this is this was the
the main thrust of it so she's blaming
the NRA for all of this and that is just
unacceptable it's irrelevant he wasn't
using a silencer it's stupid because
that's not how silencers work the idea
that the silencer would preventing
people from hearing that all a silencer
does is it prevents damage to the ears
of the person who's firing the gun
silencers do not silence guns okay when
I meant they they reduced the volume of
course but it doesn't sound like it
doesn't die hard like if you watch a die
hard if you watch any of these older
movies where somebody puts a silencer on
a pistol and then they fire it and it
sounds basically like an envelope
opening register it sounds like right
then that's not when he gun sounds like
when fired with the silencer I've fired
a gun with a silencer it sounds like a
jackhammer it's very very loud
beyond that the reason that this shooter
presumably didn't use a silencer is
because silencers can overheat and
prevent the firing mechanism from
working properly this guy knew what he
was doing he apparently had multiple
firing positions inside his suite in the
Mandalay Bay and was firing down into
the crowd so Hillary doesn't know she's
talking about it's irrelevant it's
ignorant and it's doing something else
which I find really atrocious and that
is doing the same routine I blamed Piers
Morgan for back after Sandy Hook
standing on the on the evils of this
situation and the horrors of this
situation in order to make a political
point and suggesting the people who
disagree with her about things like
silencers don't care enough about the
people who are just shot first of all I
would just suggest this is a country
music concert I would bet you the
majority of the people in that crowd are
not
of Hillary Clinton's have gun
regulations even the people who are in
the crowd even the victims I'm sure many
men not the people who are who I don't
speak for people who are dead or people
who are shot so I shouldn't say that but
I will say that a lot of people at a
country music concert that's a crowd
that's more likely to be pro-gun than
other men than other crowd so Hillary
Clinton Clinton can't even speak on
behalf of those people with accuracy
okay I want to talk in a second about a
couple of other reasons it's
inappropriate to immediately jump to
legislative proposals without evidence
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so for anyone who's excited
about this fall if you're just looking
to help a loved one or give something
nice to a loved one you need to go over
to my friends at ProFlowers they have
long lasting bouquets and your favorite
fall colors their best selling is
cinnamon cider roses a great option for
a birthday or go with one of the
classics like a hundred autumn blooms or
a dozen autumn roses you can't lose
because no matter what bouquet you send
right now you get 20% off any of
ProFlowers unique bouquets of 29 dollars
or more ProFlowers is just great it
shows up at the house you can pick the
date you want it to show up and these
flowers are guaranteed to last at least
7 days they're guaranteed fresh for at
least 7 days or you get your money back
and if they break so if it comes and
it's broken in delivery if the vase is
broken they'll replace it we've had that
happen they're great about it they just
replace it right away to get 20% off all
bouquets of $29 or more go to
proflowers.com that's proflowers.com use
my code benzo at checkout that's
proflowers.com and use code Bend show at
checkout again proflowers.com use Ben's
show at checkout and get 20 percent off
all bouquets of 29 dollars or more
whenever I'm out of town I send my wife
flowers using Pro flowers and yes I use
my own promo code Ben show in order to
get the discount so go over to
proflowers.com and he's been show a
check out so as I say people on the left
immediately jumped to political
positioning Elizabeth Warren said the
routine we have to do something now
something now to stop it
so talk in a second about what could be
done to stop these sorts of things if
anything but she's not the only one
Richard Dawkins the famous atheist
tweeted out something quite disgusting
he tweeted out Duren tootin great
shootin cool dudes certain his second
Amendment rights hell yeah and he smells
rights RA HT asked is supposed to be in
a southern accent every country has its
Psychopaths in u.s. they have guns okay
well in Britain they've been murdering
people you know they'd had multiple
terror attacks including in Manchester
using weapons and bombs and you know
that this idea that it's only in the
United States we have to worry about
this stuff is just not true but Richard
Dawkins could use a little bit of God
because apparently he lost his tact in
his decency when he lost his God there
are a few problems with with jumping to
conclusions here one again we still do
not know the shooter's motive this
happened last night we still have no
inkling of the shooter's motive how this
how this should require his weapons we
still don't know
so suggesting laws that we don't know
would stop this guy from acquiring the
weapon in the first place is always
troublesome now to be intellectually
honest I want to say you can propose a
good law that doesn't necessarily deal
with this specific situation right it's
not like every law has to deal with the
specific situation at hand if it reduces
the probability of a situation like this
or if it doesn't even have to do with
this situation but it's going to make
things safer generally right you pass a
seatbelt law that has nothing to do with
the mass shooting the seatbelt law can
still be good but it's dishonest to
suggest that using a situation like this
to push a law that wouldn't have stopped
the situation like this the two things
are related because they're not right if
you if you use this to push a child
safety law about cribs that's obviously
unrelated well if you use this incident
to pass a law or push a law or push a
policy that has nothing to do with this
particular shooting again unrelated is
unrelated and then there's a final point
this is something that we all fall into
whether on the right and on the left
when something bad happens we
immediately jump to what could the
government have done what should the
government have done making policy in
the heat of passion is not a good way to
make policy it's why we don't have a
democracy it's why we have a republic it
was to shield policymaking from the
passions of the public use to shield
policymaking from the problems inherent
in getting very emotional and passionate
about situations you know the fact is
that policy is best made when we're at a
bit of a remove injecting emotional
accusation since the process does not
make things better it just makes things
more polarized we saw this after Barack
Obama would push gun control after every
mass shooting and people would say wait
a second are you implying I don't care
when people get shot just because we
disagree all it doesn't make people it
were unified and how evil this is we're
Americans we're brothers and sisters
polarizing the electorate on the basis
of a policy and suggesting that people
who disagree with you don't care about
shootings like this is really nasty what
I say about this is now is a good time
to shut up about policy it's actually a
really good time to contemplate the
nature of human evil to get
all the information and stay silent
there will be plenty of time to talk
policy in I'm not I'm telling you wait
six months I'm telling you wait 48 hours
wait 24 hours there will be plenty of
time to talk policy when all of the
details are out and then we can have a
real good debate about what are the cost
and benefits of policies because as I
say you could pass a policy tomorrow it
would violate the Second Amendment but
you could try to pass a policy banning
all guns in the United States but that
is costs and it has benefits and it has
risks and it has rewards but we have to
discuss those rationally without
suggesting that people who disagree
somehow don't care when bad things
happen to good people pictures from this
whole thing are horrifying and I want to
talk a little bit about the nature of
evil because there's one there there's
one word that I've steadfastly attempted
to avoid when discussing issues like
that and that is the word tragedy you'll
see a lot of people today use the word
tragic I don't use the word tragedy in
relation to acts of human evil a tragedy
is what happened in Puerto Rico a
tragedy is a natural disaster that
happens an unavoidable an unavoidable
incident a cancer that hits somebody and
they die of illness right that's a
tragedy it's not a tragedy when somebody
evil does an evil thing that's an act of
evil that's an act of evil and this
person bears full responsibility for
that this person will burn in hell for
what they did today and it's just
horrifying in every way so let's talk
about evil you know I think that it's
very easy when when horrible things
happen for us to say evil is something
other evil is something alien evil is
something that's not us right it's just
something that's far away from us and we
have to discuss in situations like this
what is the exact type of evil that
we're talking about because there are
actually several types of evil evil is
not just one big amorphous thing evil is
a descriptor of act if you talking about
accident is a big amorphous thing right
though an act to kill a child is evil
but when we talk about evil people or
evil belief systems we have to
distinguish what makes a person evil or
a belief system evil other than just the
act because again there are many types
of things that drive people to do those
evil things that's what we're talking
about now the evil motivation and how we
make policy is largely dependent on what
kind of evil motivation were talking
about here
so there's a guy named Roy Baumeister
Roy Baumeister is a psychologist and
he's also a terrific writer he has an
entire book called evil inside human
violence and cruelty I've quoted it in
some of my college speeches and he
breaks down evil into basically four
forms of evil and I think
important to talk about these four forms
of evil and determine with what we saw
last night was one of these four forms
or was it something else so here are the
four forms of evil that Baumeister talks
about the first form of evil is what he
calls instrumental evil instrumentality
this is the idea that you have an object
in mind and you don't care what means
are used in order to gain that end you
want money you don't care that it's not
your money you go to the bank you rob it
you shoot somebody that is instrumental
evil right this is suicide bombers who
think that they are doing some greater
good by killing a bunch of children in a
pizzeria
that's instrumental evil the ends
justify the means and that's when we all
have to be careful with because we all
are ten we have a tendency to fall for
that right that's an easy human one to
fall into you Mon you wonder why good
people become evil that's an easy one to
fall into to say my ends are so
important it doesn't matter if I treat
another human being as a means ok the
second form of evil that Baumeister
talks about or the second motive for
evil and so he calls threatened egotism
he says that violence was isn't
perpetrated by those with low self
esteem but those with relatively high
self esteem or self esteem that was
threatened here's what he said he said
quote violence is perpetrated by a
subset of people who think well of
themselves and indeed it mainly occurs
when they believe that their favorable
images of self have been threatened or
attacked this is the danger inherent
this is when I talk about at college
campuses this is the danger inherence
and what we call microaggressions
culture right the idea that you're being
insulted and therefore you have the
right to lash out at somebody that's a
kind of evil we also have to watch out
for in ourselves and I would suggest
that we have to be careful when we talk
politics because of this right we have
to stop feeling offended when we
disagree politically we have to stop a
tributing evil motives two people who
disagree with us because then we're more
likely to become evil ourselves when
third form of evil is idealism this is
really just a subset of instrumentality
this is though the people who believe
that communism justifies the murder of a
hundred million people because we're
creating utopia the closer we we tried a
huge utopia they quote them further
remove away from human freedom and
justify violence and finally their
sadism right sadism is the least common
type of evil it's the one that we tend
to attribute evil acts to the most but
it's actually the least common type
sadism is the idea that you enjoy
violence right you're just a kid to
torture puppies and now you got a new
murder human-beings
this is very very uncommon his theory is
that it would be more common except for
guilt that we all have guilt and so if
we do something bad we feel bad about it
once that
is removed then we have a tendency to
engage in further evil now the reason
I'm breaking down these types of evil is
because when we make policy we have to
determine what sort of evil we're
fighting several of these types of evil
are actually only fightable
they're only compatible through moral
education right so ends justify the
means thinking that is only compatible
through moral education you can have
laws on the books that stop people from
from committing violence but that's not
going to help you if people are willing
to break those laws in order to achieve
a higher and moral education is the only
way that you can prevent that that's not
something that can be done at the
governmental level has to be done at the
individual level at the community level
at the school level that's something
that we all have a part in helping to
prevent well how about how about
threatened egotism that the motive that
Springs from threatened egotism well
there I think that it's important again
moral education has to take a take a
hand here we all have to acknowledge
that political disagreements do not
involve a blight on your on your
identity idealism the same thing your
ideals do not justify violence this is a
moral education issue sadism is one
where you know and if this looks like a
sadistic crime which it may well be or
if this is a crime of mental illness
that's the one where we can talk public
policy because the problem is with all
the other three you're talking about
everyone is susceptible to it everyone
is susceptible to instrumental evil
everyone is susceptible to idealistic
evil everyone is threatened is
susceptible to threaten the egotism evil
so if you promulgate a regulation
targeting any of those three things or
any of those three types of people
you're going to threaten you're going to
take away rights from everyone the only
types of people that we can profile are
sadists and mentally ill people those
are the only types of people that we can
profile this is why you see the the
great discrepancy between how the left
describes stuff like this talking about
the instruments of evil the guns and the
right talks about how do we actually
stop people from committing these
actions to complete they're two
completely separate conversations now to
talk a little bit more about that in
just a second but first I want to
suggest that you go over my Patriot
supply right now and prepare yourself
with new survival food supplies so if
you look at what just happened the
hurricane in Puerto Rico if you look
what's happened in Houston or what's
happened in Florida if you look at the
earthquakes that have been happening in
various locales around the world or if
you just see you know terrible terror
attacks you know that there may be times
where you are forced to shelter in place
if your force
turn place you're gonna want food you
don't want to have to run out to the
grocery store the grocery store may be
empty anyway it's very important that
you have enough food at home to take
care of your family for a while in case
you can't leave the house well that's
why you need to go over to eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or online and prepare
with Ben Calm it's 99 bucks plus free
shipping my paper my Patriot supply
these are the people I would trust all
the people in the office have tasted the
food they say that it really is quite
good eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen prepare with Ben calm
$99 is not a lot of money in order to
ensure that your family is safe in case
of a crisis eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen prepare with Ben
calm again this prepare with Ben calm
okay so the reason that I discuss evils
because I think this is what
conservatives tend to do we tend to say
okay how do we stop people like this
evil piece of garbage who shot five
hundred people in Las Vegas last night
how do you stop people like that from
doing what they do how do we separate
those people from guns and the left says
if everybody is susceptible to to being
bad
then nobody should have a gun well the
reality is that the vast majority of
people who are susceptible to being bad
are not people who do this and I still
agree with the basic argument that the
only way to stop a guy with the gun is a
guy with a gun and in this particular
case it was law enforcement because this
was a planned terror attack that was
occurring from a vantage point high up
or only law enforcement could do
something about it but there have been a
number of situations where people with
guns have stopped people with guns that
is that is certainly the case all the
arguments for the Second Amendment don't
stop applying just because somebody
misused the Second Amendment or obtain
their gun illegally we don't even know
how this guy obtained his gun in the
first place so again there'll be lots of
time to discuss the policy implications
of all this tomorrow all I would suggest
for everybody is that we focus in on how
we cleanse our own hearts of the
tendency to do evil things how we look
at the world and and that we think a
little bit more about the fact that
we're all brothers and sisters in this
fight against evil people and we really
need to focus together on how we can
make our country a better place across
the board without tearing each other
apart
over-over simple political disagreements
because I see that happening too much
and I find it really inappropriate and
quite disgusting okay so in other news
the presidents of the United States is
in hot water over everything that's
happening in Puerto Rico so there's been
a bit of a controversy over whether
what's happening in Puerto Rico is
really Trump administration failure or
if it's the media blowing it out of
proportion this is one of the problems
of the country where we've all lost
trust right the media we feel is a
partisan is a partisan
Hit Factory and that's exactly right on
the other hand we look at the Trump
administration we can't say we trust
these people to tell us the truth about
what's going on in Puerto Rico
after all they have a stake in the game
the same way that any administration
would have a stake in the game so I'm
gonna give you some information I'm not
an expert about about hurricane
preparedness or hurricane we're
hurricane cleanup or disaster cleanup or
disaster relief I'm not
expert on this I assume you're not
either so I'm going to allow a couple of
different experts to talk about this
because I think that it's important to
get the most objective view that we can
because all that I'm hearing from one
side is that Trump is Hitler and he's
not doing the right he's not saying the
right thing he's letting people starve
because they're brown and all this and
on the other side that Trump is the
greatest relief president that ever
lived and everything that he's done is
pitch perfect and all this is an unfair
hit job so here is an article from
Bloomberg com courtesy of a guy named
Tobin Harshaw and he and he interviewed
a retired Navy captain named Jimi
Hendrix so Jimi Hendrix is Jerry Hendrix
and not faded guitarist he's a senior
fellow with the Center for a new
American security and he served for
decades both on the high seas and in
high-level staff jobs including with the
Chief of Naval Operations Executive
panel and the office of the
undersecretary of defense for policies
irregular warfare quadrennial defense
review he has degrees from Purdue
Harvard the Naval Postgraduate and and
here's what he said what he suggested is
that the Trump administration is
actually doing a pretty good job he says
he doesn't think the criticism has been
fair he says there's a fair amount of
anticipatory action that is not being
recognized amphibious ships including
the light amphibious carriers Kearsarge
and wasp and the amphibious landing ship
dock Oak Hill were at sea and dispatched
to Puerto Rico ahead of the hurricanes
impact these are large ships that have
large flight decks to land in dispatch
heavy lift ch-53 helicopters to and from
disaster sites they also have big well
decks exposed surfaces that are lower
than the foreign after the ship from
which large land and craft can be
dispatched ashore carrying over 150 tons
of water food and supplies on each trip
you're seeing a lot of rumors online
about problems distributing the supplies
throughout the country because of
unionized truck businesses or
impassibility of the roads that has
nothing to do with Trump these are
actually the ideal platforms he says for
relief operations only to their range of
assets the ships due to their designs to
support marina amphibious landings and
war zones also have hospitals aboard and
he says that the there is a broad
misunderstanding of the USS comforts
mission this is a hospital ship that was
sent it was kind of held up and then
sent later that she was not an emergency
response ship at a hospital ship she was
built to accompany a large military
force into war zones and says it's
revelatory of where the u.s. group mind
is now that when the
in public thinks about the ships like
comfort and mercy they automatically
think of them as part of a civilian
emergency response force rather than
quietly considering the type of
potential conflict that require a
hospital ship with a thousand beds I can
tell you when I think that these ships I
internally shudder at the thought of the
type of conflict they were intended to
support he says that basically they're
their ways that the Trump administration
could be doing better but they're not
doing badly at all so that's one
perspective the other perspective is
coming courtesy of the Washington Post
so the Washington Post suggests that the
Trump administration has not sent enough
people they compared the US response to
Hurricane Maria in Puerto Rico with the
US response under george w bush or sorry
under a barack obama of the haitian
earthquake in january 2010 so a couple
of differences the Haitian earthquake in
January 2010 end up killing something
with a hundred thousand people a glitter
a hundreds of thousands of people died
we don't have body count on Puerto Rico
so we don't know how bad the damage is
in comparison to Haiti but here's what
they say they say eight days after
Hurricane Maria ripped across
neighboring Puerto Rico just 4,400
servicemembers were participating in
federal operations to assist the
devastated island army general told
reporters on Thursday in addition about
a thousand Coast Guard members were
aiding the efforts forty US military
helicopters were helping deliver food
and water to 3.4 million residents of
the u.s. territory along with ten Coast
Guard helicopters and then there a bunch
of people who helped out in Haiti who
said that they are not happy with the
level of support they say within two
days of Haiti's earthquake the Pentagon
had eight thousand American troops in
route within two weeks thirty-three
military ships and twenty-two thousand
troops it arrives more than three
hundred military helicopters buzzed
overhead delivering millions of pounds
of food and water so they're suggesting
that basically this is a fraction of
what was of what was done with Haiti
again I don't have the expertise so I'm
just going to present you with the facts
without making a hard-and-fast judgment
suffice it to say I'm seeing credible
people on both sides of the aisle some
saying that all of this is basically
going as planned and some people saying
that this is obviously not sufficient so
before you start believing all the
rumors that everything is a disaster
area I don't think that that is I don't
think all the information is on one side
here's a video that's been released from
the US Coast Guard showing what the
Coast Guard is doing to try and do
cleanup in Puerto Rico and this is my
old rosado of US Coast Guard Special
Agent Victor some damage
but not to the extent that we
experienced yesterday that we witness
yesterday it was people lost everything
in their houses save everything
everything they just the only thing they
had and it seems like whatever they they
were wearing that was what's left
looking after homes and seeing where the
water line was pretty much chest level
for me it was definitely it was
definitely a challenge to keep it
together when we started distributing
the supplies throughout the community I
was sad I was sad looking at the
conditions that work that's being done
on the ground and and you wouldn't see a
lot of these videos except for the fact
that a lot of these branches and
military actually have their own PR
wings this has been contrasted with San
Juan Mayor Carmen you lean crews so she
is a very very left-wing mayor from San
Juan she apparently has has supported
particular terrorist groups in the past
that are left-wing in terms of her
heretic and she went on national TV to
rip president Trump and of course the
media ate it up
well maybe from where she's standing
it's a good news story when are you
drinking from a creek it's not a good
news story but you don't have food for a
baby it's not a good news story when you
have to pull people down from their
buildings because you know I'm sorry but
that really upsets me and frustrates me
you know get a lot I won't ask her to
come down here and visit the towns and
then make a statement like that which
frankly it is an irresponsible statement
and it contrasts with the statements of
support that I have been getting since
yesterday when I got that call from the
White House this is an damnit this is
not a good news story this is a people
are dying story this is a life or death
story this is there's a truckload of
stuff that cannot be taken two people
story okay so as the the media of course
eats this up and suggests that she is
exactly right this is gonna be Trump's
Katrina and the media's alacrity to
cover this thing and their apparent
unwillingness to talk to other people on
the ground is quite striking here there
there's some problems with with this
particular mayor who seems like she has
a lot of time for TV and not as much
time to actually do the things she's
supposed to do so she admitted in a
press conference that she had not met
with the Federal Emergency Management
she was invited to do so and shouldn't
even bother to do it will you people
from my administration people from my
administration have been to the COI yes
but she has not apparently so while
she's ripping Trump up and down she is
she has not visited the FEMA
headquarters
she was also apparently wearing at one
point she had a shirt made up it said
help us we are dying so she had time to
make a custom t-shirt that she could
wear on TV but but her management of the
crisis has not been great to say the
least there's always this sort of
blaming him that goes on by the way
between local authorities and the
federal authorities remember after
Katrina Mayor Ray Nagin who was largely
responsible for the tragedy in New
Orleans who told people to stay in town
made it a voluntary evacuation instead
of a mandatory evacuation he blamed the
federal government the media ate that up
the governor Kathleen Blanco she blamed
the feds and of course the media ate
that up is funny when all the locals
were saying that Obama wasn't doing
enough during the Louisiana flooding a
few years ago then the media wasn't
quite so well they weren't hustling
quite so much to get those people on TV
and I'm gonna show you the other side
I'm gonna show you the people who are
saying this mayor is is basically
speaking inaccurately she always say but
first I want to say thank you to our
friends over at stamps.com so if you
don't feel like standing in line at the
post office and you know waiting there
for hours to get the stamps that you
need or to measure the postage or you
just don't feel like hanging out with
all those people if you want me quick
and efficient that's what stamps.com
is for so stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your fingertips you can buy you can
print official US postage for any letter
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and printer they make it
really easy over at snaps com they send
you a digital scale so you can calculate
how much postage you need and then
they'll help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs and then you
can actually print the postage directly
onto a piece of paper and tape it to
your envelope or your package you can
print it directly onto a sticker you can
paint it prints it directly onto the
envelope itself you don't have to lease
an expensive postage meter stamps kaam
is terrific because we use it here at
daily wear our offices all the time
right now you can enjoy stamps comm
service with a special offer it includes
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps comm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Shapiro that stamps
comm click on that mic at the top of the
homepage and enter promo code
Piro you get a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitments for that special
office for that special offer rather go
to stamps comm promo code Shapiro you
never have to go to the post office
again okay so the media has been
granting a lot of credibility to this
son one mayor who apparently is not
doing the world's greatest job but here
is the Puerto Rico governor saying the
feds are answering our calls like we
want more stuff but they're doing what
they can do you know there was a good
article that Brocklin Santino taro out
of Guaynabo if I'm not pronouncing that
correct is basically saying look there's
been excellent communication with not
only the governor but also FEMA and the
way that we're trying to tackle is you
know we can choose to look at what the
mayor spouts off or what other people
spout off but we can also choose to see
what's actually being done and that's
what I would ask okay and the the Puerto
Rican governor has also said that the
feds are answering so Trump responds to
all of this and he's very angry and you
can see why he's mad because the media
of course have jumped on this with both
feet so for example Saturday Night Live
called Trump a cheap cracker really this
is what they said because Trump
responded to the San Jose mayor by
insulting the Senate or the sound of
Juan mayor because he insulted the San
Juan mayor while we did his response
first so here are his tweets about the
San Juan mayor so he responded to the
town mayor by saying the mayor of San
Juan who was very complimentary only a
few days ago has now been told by the
Democrats that you must be nasty to
Trump okay again I think that the
President of the United States has the
right to say the mayor of San Juan I I
understand why she's emotional but she's
incorrect about the about the way that
we're treating this we were treating
this with the highest level of
seriousness which is why all of the
experts say that we're doing what we can
do is why the governor says this it's
why the other mayor's say this instead
to go after and say she's nasty to Trump
he's making it more personal even than
it was that's not the way to unify or to
to move above the debate do I blame him
for this this is Trump I mean what what
would you expect he feels like he was
maligned and he's gonna hit back against
that and I don't think that he's
completely wrong to do so he continues
along these lines and he and he tweets
such poor leadership ability by the
mayor of San Juan and others in Puerto
Rico who are not able to get their
workers to help again here is where he
starts to veer off so as always Trump
starts from
a point that is 80% correct and he moves
in two points that are now 10% correct
right he's who are these others in
Puerto Rico who are not able to get
their workers to help can he call them
out can we know or why is he like if
we're gonna play the blame game now
let's find out who specifically is
impeding the progress here don't just
put it on the people in Puerto Rico and
then he continues along these lines he
says they want everything to be done for
them when it should be a community
effort 10,000 federal workers now on
island doing a fantastic job okay again
who are these people who want everything
to be done for them now it sounds like
he's accusing all of these people of
laziness like what is the point of this
what is the point of this he could just
say the San Juan mayor is wrong I'm
insulted by the implication that I'm not
taking this seriously of course I am
maybe she's politically motivated to say
this stuff because I see no other reason
for her to say this other than political
motivation right that I think would find
90% appropriate him going after all of
the of the people of Puerto Rico
apparently or a large swath of the
people of Puerto Rico that seems in
saying that they want everything done
for them you know that again if you're
not gonna name names then this is just
bad policy but he's very angry at the
media because the media used this as an
opportunity to to slam Trump himself so
here is here's Bernie Sanders talking
about how it is it is unspeakable to
attack the mayor of a city that has been
under water speaking from his fancy Golf
Club playing golf with his billionaire
friends attacking the mayor of San Juan
who was struggling to bring electricity
to the island food to the island water
to the island gas for the island that is
just it is unspeakable but I don't know
what world Trump is living in okay so
it's I like that it's unspeakable for
Trump to say the mayor's not doing her
job
but it's not unspeakable for the mayor
to say Trump's not doing his job that
much I don't blame on Trump I do blame
Trump for going beyond that and starting
to rip you know broad swaths of the
Puerto Rican public or governing or
governing structure I also don't also
blame Trump for for this this this image
is just not smart you know if Obama did
this we'd be ripping him up and down if
Obama had gone out and played golf in
the middle of a hurricane relief effort
and then dedicated the her dedicated the
golf tournament to the victims of the
hurricane relief I have a feeling that
everybody would been on his case and I
think rightly so it's just an image okay
so
so apparently he he got up and he
actually so if you can't see the image
it's him at this golf tournament and
here is what he said he said on behalf
of all of the people in Texas and all of
the people of if you look today and you
see what's happening how horrible it is
but we really have it under great
control Puerto Rico and the people of
Florida who have suffered over this last
short period of time with hurricanes I
want to just remember them and we're
gonna dedicate this trophy to all of
those people that went through so much
that we love a part of our great state
really a part of our great nation he
says I'll tell you what I've been
watching this thing from the beginning
and I have to say our team USA wow did
you play well I can guarantee you the
people in Puerto Rico do not give two
craps about this golfing event okay and
I don't think victims in texas or
Florida are deeply are deeply honored by
the president presenting the president's
cup to the victims of a hurricane like
unless it actually has potable water in
it I have a feeling they're not super
interested in it so that's just bad
politics Trump better than anybody
should know about the imagery here and
it's really dumb does that justify the
media's response at know the media's
response is super over-the-top so here's
SNL yesterday ripping into President
Trump calling him a cheap cracker
hurricane relief these people need help
you just did this for white people twice
do the same thing go tell Melania to put
on her flood heels get some bottled
water some food pack up some extra
Atlanta Falcons Super Bowl t-shirts and
write them a check with our money you
cheap crack up okay so first of all
calling the president that cheap cracker
imagine if somebody had said something
similarly inflammatory about Barack
Obama referring to him by race you know
would that be okay and by the way it's
an easy comedic technique to use
shocking words and then expect people to
laugh but it's really kind of gross so
no wonder Trump is mad and Trump has a
right to be mad again there's not a lot
of evidence or at least there's mixed
evidence that this puerto rican effort
is being handled badly and to suggest
that he is a quote unquote cheap cracker
is pretty incredible and trump has every
right to be upset
about all of that for sure the media are
really over the top here so i want to
talk about football fallout and then
some things i like and some things i
hate for all of those things you're
gonna have to go over to the website
right now and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily wired.com
you get the rest of the show live on
video so you get the rest of the show
later if you want to listen to it at
iTunes or SoundCloud or YouTube where
you should subscribe anyway and you can
do that for free but if you want to
actually watch the show live and see
what I'm saying in real time
then you need to go over to daily wire
comm for $9.99 a month to get my show
live to get Knowles's show live via
kleavon's show live to get all three of
those shoulders live and if your
subscriber you can write into the
mailbag and we'll answer your questions
on Fridays we do the mailbag so you get
to be part of our team that way if you
want the annual subscription then you
get it cheaper not 99 not $9.99 a month
but ninety-nine bucks a year's he saved
it off about 20 bucks off the top by
getting the annual and you also get this
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler which
you will enjoy to the very fullest of
life you know you will adjust and you
will you'll love it there's there's
nothing about it you will not love you
will love the etching you will love thee
you'll love the deliberately hand-carved
by blind nuns lettering you'll you'll
enjoy the beverages that this thing
holds it is just glorious so you got
that if you just want to listen later go
over to iTunes SoundCloud or YouTube as
I said and subscribe and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are by
far the largest and fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
so it's falling into the background now
but I do want to point out that
President Trump has won his debate with
the NFL at least in so far as the NFL
backing down and the players deciding
they no longer wanna kneel for the
anthem so I don't feel like it's too
serious today to spend time on a
tremendous amount of time on frivolities
like this like this foolishness but I do
think that it is worthwhile pointing out
that the NFL players did back down so
there was some 80s on there were 80 odd
players who who knelt last Sunday this
Sunday it was like 11 or 12 it was it
was a much lower number maybe two maybe
20 at the upper end the players decided
that it was not worth a alienating their
audiences and that's because Trump threw
a spotlight on them and the players were
stupid enough to all kneel and then the
audience said nope not into it and the
players all stood up again so you know
good for the good for the audience's for
saying it's it's wrong to kneel
I suppose good for Trump for for saying
that it's wrong to kneel because I agree
with him that it's wrong to kneel I'm
not you know I'm not glad about the way
that he went about it but again I think
it's clever upfront politically to have
done this and I'll show you
Marshawn Lynch's is it running back for
the Oakland Raiders he's also kind of a
crazy person and Marshawn Lynch showed
up at his game yesterday wearing a shirt
that says everybody versus Trump right
and said there he is you can see the
picture of him wearing this shirt that
says everybody versus Trump and
President Trump thanks you for your
20/20 donation Marshall on I mean
nothing is gonna make Trump look better
than a bunch of jerk football players
who make millions of dollars a year and
want an eel for the anthem saying that
they are against Trump it makes Trump a
very happy man every time they do this
come out and what's amazing that the
Democrats are so stupid that they're
jumping right into the they've decided
they are going to jump on every land
mine every land my must be stepped upon
multiple times until it explodes Kamala
Harris the senator from California
unfortunately my own senator over here
in California she says that no one
should feel threatened or bullied by
President Trump again I don't disagree
that President Trump shouldn't have been
bullying the NFL to suspend players but
I think the Democrats are making a very
stupid political move by trying to own
this one let's speak the truth that when
Americans demand recognition that their
lives matter or kneel to call attention
to justice
that that is an expression of free
speech I may agree with the general
point that she's making but the
Democrats wanting to own this thing not
particularly smart okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so quick things that I like so
there's a book that I read over the
weekend I was recommended me to
recommended to me by a new friend who we
are doing a Facebook live with either
today or tomorrow we did film it earlier
but we're gonna put it up a little later
that is Professor Edward phaser who
wrote five proofs of God's existence he
recommended to me a book on free well
that I read over the weekend it's very
short about 85 pages but it really is
quite concise and good it's called free
while science hasn't disproved free will
by a guy named Alfred Mele and it is
quite good it's easily readable and it
debunks a lot of these scientific
arguments on behalf of the notion that
neuroscience shows that you have no free
will and that basically you're just a
machine a self-replicating machine that
that's not the case
and this book shows that the science has
not proved it the single most important
factor for the development of a society
is your feeling of capacity to better
yourself and better the society in which
you live if we didn't feel that way
progress would stop short people would
get depressed we have a serious problem
I think that's one of the problems with
our society as it currently is
constituted check out this book for to
find out why science has overstepped its
boundaries and making some of its more
ridiculous claims about the nature of
your capacity to choose again the book
is free while science hasn't disproved
it free well good book okay other things
that I like so I ripped SNL earlier I
want to compliment SNL for a very funny
but that they did they did a bit for a
new type of jeans that they are calling
Levi's woke here is here is the bed it's
pretty funny my genes tell me I'm a man
my genes tell me I'm a woman they tell
me I'm a Mac that I'm skinny a child yo
you don't know me jeans I'm not a style
I'm not a size That's not me I am NOT a
child
I'm
me I'm unique I'm whoa whoa whoa so why
aren't my jeans now they are introducing
Lima groans sighs list style neutral
gender non-conforming denim for a
generation that defies label Levi's
heard that if you're not woke it's bad
so we made these you find someone buy
this style that's offensive that's why I
leave I wou have no style why don't you
try asking me about my accomplishments
our size of me they fit everybody
because they fit no I'm triggered this
color can you label this color that is
the color grab they not brown but they
not not brown it's a handful of colors
none of what's your dominant just like
our country oh wait
who says I have hands you the jeans whoa
do they come in men's and women's nah do
they come in person what do you think
that's why walks got unified 180 degrees
of gender not
see when SNL actually decides to be
politics neutral and go after both sides
it's so funny this is really good okay
because the whole woke thing is so
stupid and of course trying to apply two
basic elements of everyday life
demonstrates how stupid it is okay so
there we go
a thing from SNL that I like
congratulations SNL okay time for a
couple of things that I hate so here we
go okay so I was going to do this on
Friday but I must show it to you now
this is of course the pause pod so
somebody decided that it was imperative
to actually invent something called the
pause pod in which you are supposed to
sit and pause and reflect I guess you
carried around with you okay it's in a
dude getting into a tent and there's
like an actual part of the tent that
folds out to hold your legs it says take
a nap anywhere and then it's just some
creepy dude in the middle of the park
getting out of a tent like a homeless
guy near my you know near the LA River
just awesome so somebody invented a tent
and then they called it the pause pod
and apparently it's like well insulated
and also you can stick your legs out so
that somebody can trip over you
apparently you know Peter Thiel suggests
that the pace of innovation in our
society has dramatically slowed I would
think that this is pretty good proof of
that my son has a paused pot it's like a
little it's a it's a little tent that we
got him for like ten dollars and he
likes to prop it up and sit in it I
guess it's his pause pod now he does not
stink his legs out of it because he's
not a like these adults who
decided that in a public place they need
he's a year and a half and he's not
stupid enough to do this and they've
decided that they need to stick their
legs out into the public thoroughfare as
I suggested to Malthus this just seems
like ripe for robbery right like the I
mean can just imagine somebody goes to
sleep in public in a tent you just open
up the tent grab their stuff and run and
meanwhile their legs are tangled up in
there in the in the lengthening part of
the pause pod or if you really wanna get
violence about I suppose you just
chainsaw off their legs and they really
can't chase you but you know there's no
reason to get violent about it you can
also just push over the tent and laugh
that's probably what I would do so if
you ever see someone with applause pod
just know that person is not a success
in life okay other thing that I hate so
the other thing that I hate today
that John Kasich somehow thinks he's
still relevant the Ohio Governor who
basically assured that Donald Trump won
the nomination by staying in the race
far too long a man who I have said
before looks like he went through the
washing machine like a receipt in your
pocket and then was UNCHR humble he now
says that maybe he won't support the
Republicans and he'll make an
independent run because that's just what
we need America is John Kasich making an
independent run oh god no please God not
John Kasich yes John Kasich if the party
can't be fixed Jake then I'm not gonna
be able to support the party period well
okay if the party is fixed by people
like John Kasich it ain't fixed okay I
think there's serious problems in the
party I do not think that this that this
man is the one to fix the problems in
the party considering that he was too
selfish to get out of the race and let
somebody else compete this this dummy
stayed in long enough that was
impossible for anybody else to win the
nomination and here he is talking about
how he's not a factor in running the
party he this is a guy who expanded
Medicaid in his state in accordance with
Obamacare look okay go away good
riddance get out John no one likes you
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow the
rest of the week we are we are
broadcasting from abroad we are we
brought in the next two days we're
broadcasting from Sacramento and then
I'm gone for a week and a half so
treasurer these next two days treasure
our time together because it really is
precious and please seriously everybody
pray today for the state of the country
now pray today for for the world and
let's pray that the evil that that is
growing it seems all over the planet and
in so many hearts and minds should be
checked by them by a more benevolent God
let's let's pray for that I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
you
[Music]